am 5 oktober besucht
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
die internationale scharf schießübung
joint feier support am
truppenübungsplatz hochfilzen ziel der
übung ist die verbesserung der
zusammenarbeit verschiedenster
waffensysteme
wirklich eine übung auf höchstem niveau
um mit den worten von oberst zu sprechen
das ist champions league das aber grund
warum wir im rahmen der european
trainings initiativ auch die lieb
funktion haben denn diese übung findet
unter internationaler beteiligung statt
rund 300 soldatinnen soldaten aus
deutschland belgien polen tschechien
frankreich und rumänien genannt dieser
übung ebenso teil wie auch 30
gefechtsfahrzeuge und schrauber
flächenflugzeuge und zwei euro weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
nutzt den rahmen der übung um zwei neue
fahrzeug gestützte radaranlagen an die
truppe zu übergeben
technologische niveau ist punktgenau
funktioniert insbesondere haben wir
beobachtet an der grenze zu ungarn den
17 bei der grenzüberwachung ich kann nur
sagen auch der griechische
verteidigungsminister war beeindruckt
und hier durften wir es im rahmen der
übung haben erleben das ist dafür
punktgenaues
arbeiten schießen einfach unabdingbar